welcome back to the 19th ever iced
coffee
what's it called hour that's how we
should do that
you're good you're good keep it in there
no edits keep going oh okay uh we have
made to date 4790
and in this video that we will get
demonetized and we'll probably lose some
money
i hope not now that's right brazil
first of all the lengths that we had to
go through to get you on the podcast
this is a big deal we all got uh illness
tests
right before coming on the podcast so
none of us were positive we're all
negative
but uh that was a pretty penny to get uh
tested
yeah like that it's uh but we made it
and it
it feels weird because i almost feel
like back to normal now yeah because
this has been the first social gathering
that i've had without masks
and i think even if i counted masks i've
had like two social gatherings
since the pandemic began wow and that's
six months now
six and a half months of course this is
exciting for us to have you on
because it's a huge deal because not
only did our video that we do together
where
you lost two million dollars in tesla
dude it's not like 300
000 views now wow your channel has
exploded
this year this is the year of meet kevin
no
oh yeah yeah seriously i think in a few
months
you're going to have more views total
than i will on youtube
no way you're almost at 150 million
views so far
oh my gosh and i'm at uh 196.
well now i have a goal but you're
catching up by six million views a month
wow you're gaining on me wow yeah okay
well i'm gonna i'm gonna go to five
videos a day now
good so really quick i think it's
important to know
who you are so if you wouldn't mind just
giving us like a 30-second background
for anyone who's tuning in who doesn't
know your channel
yeah totally so uh went to ucla real
estate broker i'm 28
married got two kids and uh yeah now
you know i started making youtube videos
after i saw graham
talking about real estate yeah uh and
i'm like if graham can do it
i can do it
this idiot can do it anyone could do it
but uh
and then i think i i reached out to you
uh for uh what was it a
a sprinkles cupcake yes yeah and that's
how we met
uh yeah i remember your email you sent
me an email i think i was back at like
60 thousand subscribers or 50 000
on the channel you reached out and your
email was basically we're like the same
person
really that that's how it sounded how so
what what in the email the similarities
between them do you have it i'm sure i
can find it hold on one sec
you know it wouldn't surprise me because
we both started buying real estate so
early and that's something i always try
to pay to drive home is
buy real estate buy real estate and
that's if there's anything i did well
over the last 10 years it's it's just
buying real estate i still
i can never spell your last name even to
this day
kevin yeah first name meet okay got it
okay
you want me to type it for you no
p-a-f-f p-a-f-f
or a-t-h you messed it up or anything
r-e-t-h not patty
r-a-t-h there we go i can't i can't it's
[Laughter]
impossible
2017. we're coming up on the anniversary
almost we're almost three years now wow
three years ago
this happened uh i'm gonna read this
no i'm drinking i mean this is just with
water of course
all right hi graham a lot of your
audience on youtube seems to be younger
and either aspiring or newer
having watched you since your 7 000 sub
days
which wasn't even that long ago congrats
i know we share a lot of the same
philosophies
and wanted to offer potential talks and
film sites renovations and progress on
either flips or rental deals
i personally don't flip now keep in mind
i have not seen this email
since back then i have not looked at it
so this is the first time i've seen this
almost three years
i'm 25 with my wife we own just over
four million dollars in properties
almost exclusively single family rentals
i usually sell about 20 million dollars
per year about 40 deals
no door knocking or fairy customer
service i'm my own broker
we just started a renovation business
exclusively for our clients
meetanddone.com we have neat ideas that
i think could benefit your channel and
offer growth in both youtube and real
estate
best wishes for your continued growth
kevin p.s i started at 18 after quitting
at red robin in almost quick college
ucla i've walked in the footsteps
of your viewers and i responded back yes
let me know when you can talk and i gave
my phone number
that's great that's it and then what
since then we've been to north carolina
where we've been we've been uh
washington dc dc was fine canada
and we've just been going to vegas oh
yeah uh giving talks on real estate and
youtube
vegas a few times yes and it seemed like
at least two of your big viral hits i
was with you
oh as they took off yeah it was the
credit card one credit card one jpm
one two maybe the tesla i forget well
yeah yeah it's amazing so hopefully we
have another banger coming tomorrow
let's get kevin o'leary to number one on
trending jeez yeah
that video was really good thank you if
you haven't watched graham's kevin
o'leary video watch it
right he basically through graham makes
fun of me
margin on stocks yeah we want to talk
about the margins let's just go right
into this
okay so tell us from the right into the
depths of the holes you made
millions of dollars in tesla's stock
yeah how did this start
yeah you know uh well i i think it all
started with just having bought the
model x and
i think one of the weirdest things was i
don't even know if i should say this but
it was when we were driving to vegas
uh we were driving somewhere and it's
just like a seven hour drive
and the car's on autopilot and it's like
i'm editing like
credit cards exposed on my laptop in the
car i remember that like three years ago
or two years ago probably at this point
uh and uh you know ever since i started
realizing this autopilot was really
so powerful i i couldn't get away from
tesla and i i'm
so cautious of of getting brainwashed
into the the hype of it because if you
look online everything's just like hype
fest on tesla especially the online
but um i don't know what do you think am
i just over
hyping tesla or but to me it's like if
if i could if i don't if i could only
pick one stock
that's the only stock so but back then
how much did you invest in tesla stock
okay so uh when i first bought the car
it sucked
so nothing and then it got better why
would you say it sucked
oh it was horrible the crap i went
through with the car i have an old old
video somewhere but
i had almost every time i went to get in
the car i would have errors
so you'd get in it was autopilot not
available car can't start car needs
service
there was a time where i was late for an
appointment i got in and it was doing
some weird bugs i called tesla and they
said here's what you got to do
take your key walk five minutes away
from the car
so so you're distant from the car so the
car can just hard reset alone
wow and then i came back and the problem
was i'm like what this is the stupidest
one
i thought i bought a lemon wow yeah and
then i saw the car
go from lemon to not lemon and i'm like
they did that
all over the air that's new you know
wow so i think that's really what got me
so inspired
uh and then uh you know how heavy did i
go on tesla i think i probably was 400k
in on tesla before the pandemic
before the pandemic yeah okay so what
was your average buy-in because you were
buying it a lot i remember
uh when i sold at 9 14 you were buying
more
i still buying yeah let's look at it
right now uh the
uh you know i hope i didn't mess up the
mic there but before the pandemic and i
just sold a little bit right before
battery day
because we'll talk about that in a
second here uh but let's pop it up so
here's
tesla this is just the m1 finance so
it's 190. ease man
look at that 90. and it's what 3.4 or
whatever in
you have more in tesla than i have in
the entire market right now
and it's very poorly diversified i think
the only way i could which i heard in
in the kevin o'leary video right five
percent per stock and i'm like
nah that ain't me you went against
everything that he said with the margin
but you made money do you think that was
luck or do you think that there's
strategy behind this yeah i mean it's
it's always hard to say looking back i
think um
i think probably what really messed me
up was back when i was
initially buying real estate all i would
do when i was saving money in between
deals was by apple
and it always did well for me over the
last decade and for me i almost see
tesla as like the next decades the tesla
decade
and i think they're just at the
beginning of their growth curve you know
now we look at the stock it's like oh
it's exponential
i think it's the start of an exponential
curve for them
we'll see i mean who knows and i don't
want to just come here and tesla hype
everything isn't that scary
though to have so much money in tesla
what's your margin right now
yeah um so if if what i did is
uh so i've got my robinhood margin paid
off i've got my weeble margin paid off
because there was a point in july where
i was like really heavy
in in margin is that like three million
a margin right uh
more more probably probably at one point
i was somewhere around like three and a
half to four million in margin
yeah uh and so one of the one of the
reasons for that though
is on some deals i had to panic close
quickly on some that like for example
had a real estate deal
where the seller was in hospice
going to die any day and the lender is
like we just need a one week extension
we need a one week extension the
seller's like
he's not gonna make it and then we're
gonna go into probate and then i'm not
gonna get the deal
and so there were probably about three
deals this summer where i took around
one and a half million dollars out just
to buy real estate cash
so my view has always been okay well if
i'm if i'm borrowing a margin to
buy real estate cash i always have that
as a piggy bank
so if necessary i can get a loan on that
real estate
and uh and sort of break that piggy bank
and then pay down margin
that's true yeah but it's slow right uh
refinance these days 45
days worst case you could always get a
hard money loan at like 10 or 11 percent
for like a year that's true anyone would
lend you with that bridgette
right that's a good point yeah yeah yeah
so i
i think that real estate really gave me
the confidence to maybe be
hyper focused on individual stocks which
is probably a mistake but i i think real
estate is my biggest diversity
i mean now uh this month uh
the first couple weeks of october once
this next one closes uh i'll i'll be at
like 16
in real estate in the total right i have
mortgages on these
million for anyone yeah and and i was
just
i was on my run with lauren today so 16
million in the debt's probably somewhere
around nine
uh but i was on my run with lauren today
i go even if we just averaged one
percent just appreciation alone
one percent appreciation on that's 160
grand
just one percent it's unbelievable is
this enough
because you have enough right now where
you could pay off all the margin you
could even pay off probably
a lot of the real estate sure and just
call it quits
you won that you already beat the game
yeah now you're just making us look bad
stop no no no no you know i don't
i don't know what it is i think probably
the biggest problem i have is working
too much
uh it's just always you know not not
having enough time for the family or the
kids or putting work
first and and so now i'm trying to do
this new schedule where i'm working from
five to two is is the goal so i wake up
at like 4
57 and i try to be done at two and my
view is if i can get you know three or
four videos out great
and then spend time with the family to
have that balance but
i used to in that original email that
you you pulled up there i had a
disclaimer at the bottom kevin takes
saturdays off to spend time with family
i did that for two years saturdays were
the worst
day of the entire week for two years
because because you couldn't work i got
nothing done i felt i was so anxious
about all the things i wasn't doing that
i actually felt stressed and
like like terrible about myself for
taking a day off to spend time with
family
now if i work from five to two really
hard it's like okay
you know i had some good videos or or
made some good progress in real estate
then i get off at two
and i feel really fulfilled like now i'm
gonna go on a run with a family now i'm
gonna
you know watch twilight with lauren you
know whatever
uh and uh that i don't know i think
that's almost what
what helps me have some semblance of
happiness yeah
that's the hardest thing to get why do
you think you work so much
i've lauren's been trying to figure that
out with me too it's
has it always been like this yeah it's
always been this always been like yeah
since when
when did you notice that maybe you had a
thing for work
um probably my first job uh which was
red robin
uh actually so a couple of before juice
hollister
hollister that's it yeah
as soon as i um as soon as my
manager found out that i was
volunteering for the police department
she cut my hours to zero
why why well i think her one of uh one
of the people in her family
had uh been like discriminated against
by a cop or something like that and so
i'm like well shouldn't have said that
there goes that job
so wow but i spent three years with law
enforcement yeah
uh and but yeah i mean i i don't know i
i always worked at my jobs like it was
my own business and it was really
frustrating because
i'll never forget scraping mold off the
shelves of jamba juice in the back
nobody else would do that stuff and it's
just like ah
this is my shop you know i'm gonna do it
as best as i can uh
yeah and then after a year of doing that
they gave me a 10 cent raise i'm like
i'm out of here so you've so you've
always had this knack
to want to continue working because your
work ethic is something that
i think just we're all shocked about it
like we have group texts between all the
finance people
and we're like kevin just posted his
fourth video today oh no you know
seriously and i'm not ice cream no no
so we have we have a vegas we have a
vegas chat between me jeremy and andre
okay and so it's between the three of us
that will be like did you see kevin's
like fifth video today
how does he do it how can he do this and
we're all in shock at like just
the momentum because i remember we
talked a few months ago i'm like dude
you're going to get burnt out at doing
this after like three months two months
how
you're not going to sustain it you've
done it you've like doubled the length
where i thought you would be able to do
it not get burnt out
it's quite bizarre uh nowadays with with
this new schedule that i have the the
five to two
i wake up in the morning and i'm jazzed
to do it
like i don't know what it is i'm just
like oh my gosh i can't believe jerome
powell did this all right
like and that sounds like so stupid but
for me uh it's it's almost like dual
purpose because
the more i know about what's going on in
the government and the more i could see
that's going on with stimulus or
or the fed or whatever the more it makes
me feel comfortable about my real estate
investments yeah
let's let's go deeper why why work so
much what does that give you
yeah like i'm trying i'm trying to get
down for like self fulfillment
you know because the reason is i'm the
exact same way yeah so like i'm trying
to
get your perspective and your point of
view to better understand mine
yeah i'm the same way like i just i love
it like i'm excited to wake up
every single morning be like okay now i
could get to work i love it there's
something about it that
just makes me feel fulfilled i'm curious
from your perspective
yeah i i can't say that it's a dollar
amount just because lauren and i
we don't spend much on ourselves you
know i'll buy
equipment anything that that i could
justify is work related i'll spend a lot
of money on
uh but uh yeah i don't know because
you're right i mean
we i was thinking about it too it's just
sell all the stocks
pay off half the properties uh and just
just coast i mean i could also just sell
everything and put our entire net worth
into 18 t
and and take a seven percent dividend
and not have to work ever again
uh you know so
i i don't i don't know why i think you
don't know what's the weird thing is
it's not it can't be a number you gotta
have
you gotta have an idea it can't it's not
a number i know that
uh number doesn't mean much they can't i
think maybe is it notoriety
is it is it having a sense of having a
purpose what that's it that's it so not
it's purpose purpose more like
i i feel like one of the things that i i
love doing that a lot of people
don't love so much is buying
fixer-uppers and then
holding them as rentals especially here
in california that's a hard thing to
grasp like why
why does that make sense because the
cash flow's not that great out here uh
and i think really expanding on that
business model is something that that
i'm just
so jazzed about uh something that that i
could just i could keep doing and i
don't have a boss
i could do that myself what purpose does
that give you any mental properties
well you know this is it's almost like a
uh
i studied uh some philosophy at ucla
where they're like okay well what's the
purpose of this what's the purpose
and it all goes down i remember
aristotle said it all comes down to
living a good life
was was their conclusion and i read
those because i'm i have the same
curiosity as you like what's the bottom
line like why am i doing all this right
there are some days you wake up and
you're like i don't want to do anything
or you wake up excited and then then you
can't get anything done like the
creativity doesn't come
right those days happen so there are
frustrations that come with it all and
yeah it makes you wonder like we'll just
quit and forget everything
but i don't know here i am i just keep
waking up every day but you haven't
thought about why
what's your end result what's the end
goal no
uh because i i tell lauren i go so what
are we gonna do
we're just gonna go live in in uh yeah i
mean one day i'd love to live on like
the coast of spain or
uh the coast of uh france or something
have that mediterranean climate like we
do
uh here in socal but but just live
somewhere over there on the
mediterranean sea and just hang out like
in all those movies
uh but i don't know that i'm ever gonna
do it because i just keep working
and it's almost like a sin like why like
stop
i don't know do you think you'd be happy
if you were to just completely stop
working because
i think you're similar to kevin o'leary
because he said that what he wanted to
do was finally retire
so he took three years of his life where
he said he wanted to visit every single
like famous beach in the world oh wow
yeah that's what he said he wanted to do
and he went and he did that but then he
wanted to come home
so bad like a year into it because he
was miserable he just wanted to continue
working
do you think that that's something that
you could see yourself doing like i
could see that
you know having that experience with
those saturdays off and it's so weird
because i remember being in high school
and it's like
school sucks you know like school
i would ditch school and yeah i would
always get detention
or i didn't you know suspended from
school internal suspension they called
it
uh and i would do anything to escape uh
so i'd park my car in the construction
yards so there's no gate to get out and
so i could go play world of warcraft
that was like my childhood uh runescape
splinter cell or whatever uh i hate it's
cool and i think it's almost like if
if if you're just not like i can grow
with this
i saw no growing with school i'm like i
hate it it sucks
get me out of here but with this i feel
like i can keep growing i can
i can keep buying houses i could keep
fixing up
crappy houses and and getting tenants
into houses and keep doing it why
i don't know i feel like a rat on a
hamster wheel but i like my wheels
what is it about it that you like so
much the houses yeah
yeah it's cause it sounds like it's not
money
is it the challenge is it i mean the
before and afters are nice
you know but uh i got tired of it at
first i
loved being able to put your own touch
on a house like for me it was like
supposed to be like that's
my house i own that one and put all your
own touches on it and colors on it
people drive behind you like i picked
out that color
those trims and those are my hedges out
front it's cool
but after a while now i'm like i'm over
it i'm not i'm not trying to get more
work like that
true you know that's interesting you
said that it's almost i'm thinking
now it's almost like becoming a game
like how
uh little can i spend per project and
they all have the same formula
so it's the same cabinet pane it's the
same wall paint it's the same baseboards
to the point where the people that i
work with the the crew that i work with
great great guys uh was just like all
right here's another one
and they already walk in they go all
right i know i gotta get this this this
it makes it so easy to wear when i'm off
at two i go check in on the properties
and the guys are doing great stuff and
so
i think maybe another vision that i have
is uh
part of what you read in that email that
meet and done business
is uh if i can have a lot of
employees so to speak or maybe just
workers because they're all 1099 they
make their own schedule they come when
they want to work
but uh workers that i could constantly
provide work for
and if i had just like an army of
amazing people like that like don't
worry i got another project for you i
got another project for you and they
were able to come to work not have to
deal with
clients not have to deal with call backs
not have to deal with all the crap
that contractors usually have to deal
with because it's the same formula
every property is exactly the same
there's no mystery to it i think that
almost gives me happiness like i feel
happy just talking about the idea of
like an army of 200 people that always
have work that i'm able to provide for
them okay
yeah is it 200 and right now it's three
at one point and that's the future goal
is is the army vision
no right now it's three really great
workers uh and
uh like you know a great painter great
other people but yeah
in the future i think that that would be
such a wonderful thing my failure with
meet and done
was doing work for other people explain
what meet and done is
yeah so meet and done was uh my vision
of being a real estate broker to where i
could go to somebody to say i'll sell
your house the way it is
or you can hire my contracting business
why is that blinking right there yeah
it's so
this is a a crappy canon r that they
charge
like three grand for and it overheats
so overheating so it's overheating on on
i didn't think it would do that on 1080p
but yeah it's overheating so uh in a few
minutes it'll melt and we'll just look
at the other camera
okay yeah uh yeah
they say there's a firmware update or
i'm still within amazon's 30-day return
policy and it's going back
jeez okay whatever uh yeah where uh so
uh renaults people mean that mean done
yes
real estate broker hey you want to sell
your house hey i could sell your house
as
this you could also hire my contracting
business and we'll fix it up for you
and we'll even do a loan for you we'll
lend you the money to fix it up that was
meet and lend
and then lauren would come in and do
meet and stage
you guys everything no literally top to
bottom or we'll just buy it as
is as a cash investor wow yeah but where
the failure was
the business worked amazingly until i
started uh taking on
individual clients who were like no i
want this crown molding no i want
this paint no i want this cabinet it was
it went away from me
from my vision it became their vision
and i don't like that
i want my vision uh actually the more we
just talk about it the more it's almost
like
you know i think that's maybe what it is
is finding your own purpose and building
that
that reminds me you called into grant
cardone and he told you to shut that
down didn't he
that guy will he'll come back and uh
connected that camera melted that camera
will come back and we'll come back
automatically
no well we'll have to uh we'll have to
repeat recruit help here
in 10 minutes it should be is it really
going to be 10 minutes
you know i have no idea honestly uh it's
uh
it i i thought if i filmed on 1080 it
wouldn't do that
but it still does because aren't we
filming did that come out uh
it just came out like two months ago oh
yeah we film at 7 20.
uh that's pretty i don't i don't know
that it's that i think it just sucks
so um should we just get the other your
other camera i'm gonna grab the other
camera yeah let's do that
pop the other camera there so what then
made you do the switch to youtube
oh wow why why from real estate to
youtube because this has been a recent i
would say the last year
the growth or what my strength is just
focusing on you oh the switch in general
oh yeah yeah um
no i sorry i completely agree with you
oh i feel like klutz
sorry um yeah
it's um youtube was so fascinating
because i was able to
uh share my perspective which i kind of
layered initially on top
because my first video was in reference
to you or cardone you had brought that
up
uh and uh you know everybody has
different perspectives and that's the
beautiful
thing about youtube is you really have
the opportunity to share
uh hey that's a great way to do it
here's another way
and uh it's it's shocking to see that
there are people who resonate with that
i always thought like there's no way i'm
ever going to get to
10 000 subscribers or 100k oh my gosh a
dream
you got to 10k from my video yeah yeah
pretty much yeah
pretty much so you enjoy the work of
youtube more than you enjoy any other
work oh my gosh
well i enjoy you know what i think we're
we're actually creating a conclusion
here
that that you have been kind of looking
for that i didn't even know myself
that i love that i'm like fully my own
boss
because when i was constantly
representing clients when i emailed you
i was doing 40 deals
so you're talking 40 deals in a year
you're dealing with 60 70 clients
because not all of them are going to
close
so 60 or 70 i'll be more than serious
and more probably
100 yeah
not having to drop everything to do what
somebody else wants and instead
being able to have my own desires and
like no we're doing
this on this property it's it's so
fulfilling yeah you know
the the architects the the workers the
electricians
they call me what do you want to do what
do you want to do with this problem well
this is what we're going to do
i get to decide but i remember yeah but
i remember in the beginning of youtube
you took a totally different approach
from
everybody else you really made the
content unique kevin filmed in bushes
yeah he would go film in playgrounds he
would film behind buildings
i mean it was just weird stuff i
remember watching your first video on me
thinking it was like some type of hit
piece or something and then i watched it
at first i was like this is strange but
he's not saying anything bad but the
title is like
what gram stefan isn't telling you as if
i'm hiding something
and he's filming in a bush and then he's
jumping out of a playground and it's
just
weird stuff weird and
you continued that through pretty much
every single video and then you took the
pivot i think about 20
000 subscribers to do exposed videos
this was it's hilarious back at the
back back in the day when exposed videos
were a thing
like when when you put exposed in the
title people clicked
now you put exposed intel no one cares
but back then three years ago you put
grant cardone exposed maybe we bleep out
that name let's bleep out that name
but we can talk about that if you want
can we talk about it fully okay
so uh wow wow that opens up a lot so
that's a fun story
so you could do exposed videos and you
took a liking to
someone in particular the videos wrote
themselves man
you shouldn't say that
it's fine now most people don't know
this the crazy thing is now is that
you've grown so much for the stimulus
content
that no one remembers the old stuff
the real cabin the cabin that's behind
the stimulus content
used to be really good at doing exposed
videos
those were your forte what you would do
is you'd pick these like
i i did these internet gurus uh
and you would pick them apart and find
everything wrong with them
and make it unknown i mean
it's terrible the thing is i i always
loved watching these videos because they
knew it was going to be like this juicy
gossip of finance stuff
that no one would have would ever say
yeah but you would just go all out and
just say it
it was probably explain where where did
that come from uh
yeah so i think probably the the inside
kevin
uh is uh i i don't know i call myself a
little crazy like
just when there there are times when if
i could just be fully me
i'm i just feel like i'm just doing
whatever i want like fun crazy things
and those videos were almost
that expression yeah you know news
which is is more what i'm doing now
financial news
uh is really quick yeah didn't i tell
you like two and a half years ago
i don't know you should be doing news
didn't i tell you that
you did you did yeah years ago pretty
much
everything you've told me has been right
seriously i i kid you not everything
i've told you all my recommendations for
you
have been right yeah well i um i
would not be doing what i'm doing if it
weren't for
me even having reached out to you there
we go yeah no i will sincerely say that
yeah yeah i should have taken a credit
back then yeah be like you
10 of everything you make yeah yeah
kidding hey you get all my teachable
renewals
you get 30 on those do i yeah you should
you should check man otherwise they're
ripping you off
because i for sure used your affiliate
i'm paying them like five grand i don't
think
i don't think i am getting that but uh
we'll check i'll check but anyway so
what the transition so yeah but no no
the the exposed
videos back then you know it's not
something that
i almost am proud of uh it's it's uh
something that
i look back on like that's uh kevin in
his natural state
uh and uh and i think it's uh it's too
jaded
uh you know i think it's better to just
look at the positive uh so i've really
had
more of a shift there some people say
i'm too optimistic yeah
and i've always been a very optimistic
person but uh
i always thought that it was almost like
my job to be like this protector and
like no
don't tell somebody they can't buy a
single family and make a lot of money i
will make
30 videos on you yeah i almost think
it wasn't that my honest thought is that
you liked pushing the line
oh i do love that you love just like i
still do that
you know just just picking at people
like just poking them
poking and poking them and just waiting
into the moment where they finally snap
back
and i think your thing is you find it
fun to see how far away you could get
with something
before they'll they'll punch back that's
what i
that's what i honestly think yeah yeah
i'm not
i'm not good at following girls that's
another thing that gives me a lot of
happiness actually
is is having that freedom from from
rules we moved out of
uh and i love my in-laws but we moved
out of my in-laws parents house when
lauren and i were living there
because there were rules i uh i stopped
caring about school because of rules i
stopped caring about but i
think you purposely like going against
what other people are saying i think if
everyone agreed
that this candle is orange let's just
say you would purposely be like
that's a different shade of art and you
would purposely because you like that
challenge
because here's the thing here's the
thing i'll i'm gonna bring this up
back in the day you said you would never
do a course
remember that you did too i just but
that's sushi but i openly
talked about why i changed my
perspective and what led that
you said you said the same thing too but
i thought back then because i came out
with my real
estate course and i remember you saying
back then
that you were going to give the same
thing but free on youtube i said that
yeah yeah i remember that and you came
out with the whole course and then i
think you realized that
no one was watching this video that's
the problem and then you just said well
if i charge people for it now now
they're all going to watch it and they
did
yeah yeah yeah the the course transition
it was always really interesting because
i went into it and thought oh my gosh
why like i didn't monetize my channel
yeah you told me to monetize my channel
uh and uh yeah it's fascinating when
when people sign up for
a course it's almost like and they pay
money for it it's almost like they're
motivated like oh my gosh i'm gonna get
through all these sections
and people they go through like i mean
the 350 lectures i have in the
investment
like oh my gosh like people go through
this stuff and and
it's almost like they come out a
different human but uh you can't do that
on youtube
because it doesn't get views like i
can't do chapter 6.2
how to you know get the use net present
value to get the best deal on loan i
can't do that on youtube who's gonna
click on that
instead grant cardone exposed yeah boom
800 000 views baby it's true
how long do those videos take you to do
are they still up could people still
watch
sure yeah i've been asked many times to
remove them
so are you allowed to talk because then
you get cardona i could talk about all
that so okay so
you were sued twice yeah yeah oh yeah
i've been sued
uh that's why i created uh uh the shirts
don't sue me
i should have worn that don't sue me bro
yeah uh
but honestly i've i've almost tried to
distance myself from the don't sumibro
because uh it it reminds me of when when
i did take a more jaded approach
uh part of me thinks that i'm not trying
to blame it on that but part of me
thinks that was almost like a law
enforcement issue
because i think you know cops have
obviously you know not the best rap
especially in today's day and age
but having been on the road for 1500 to
2000 hours
i kind of started almost becoming jaded
because of
what it was like to be in that car uh
and to see the
the police pursuits and the brutality
and you know on all sides you know
and that it was almost like i i was
going when i was
17 18 years old just finishing up not
not doing it anymore
i'm going into the starbucks and i'm
twitching around looking where
everybody's hands are and
it really jades you and and that stuck
with me
uh until well into my twenties and i
think i'm finally becoming a lot more
like
chill and and you know more
trusting and less jade wait so what does
that have to do with the exposed videos
oh because that to me that's
totally just what what what being uh
being almost like a detective in the
police was
and we would train with either the swat
team or detectives and
case files and it was an incredible time
and i really missed that time so you're
trying to police the internet so to
speak yeah
yeah you could say that yeah yeah i
don't recommend it i cannot recommend it
no and i would never do it again if i
could come back i wouldn't do it again
didn't i told you though for the record
yes he did told you not to do that he
did it
what have you told graham have you told
graham anything that he's imagining well
now you've put me on the spot
i mean i think we share a lot of great
ideas i don't know that there's
something we can we can individually
point to but i mean we share a lot of
great ideas
that's a fancy answer of saying no no
okay
well um yeah that's another thing that
i've really just
started trying to distance myself from a
lot and this is a thing that actually
takes a lot of happiness away i notice
it
i'm just going to talk about myself but
i remember it's all about you men
no it's kind of okay in 2018
19 even a lot of
me i felt like it was me relative to
other people
right yes and that is toxic i call it
like the toxicity of relativity i think
i talked about it in your video
the first video that i did i i may have
i don't know but anyway
um the last few months
i've uh stopped looking at socialblade
i've stopped looking at uh other
people's subs and other people's videos
and sometimes people like oh didn't you
see this person's video they talked
about you and
i've almost tried to just distance
myself and just go
i'm just going to talk about what i want
to talk about which i love the financial
news i'm gonna put it out there and i
try my best to stay away
i like to be supportive so you know uh
you and jeremy i'll pop in i'll leave
comments
um but most of most of the web i just
try to
ignore it because it's comparing myself
to other people
takes all of my joy away all of like any
of the success like i could have
a great video that i put out it ranks
the best out of my last 10 videos
and then i go look at somebody else and
they got more videos faster or more
views
faster than me and i i the rest of the
day's ruined it's very miserable clear
value tax
no you know i just stephen gardner i i
mean i think they're both great uh they
have a really good way of
of uh connecting with their audience
that's one of my problems
is uh it it takes a while for people to
kind of crack the kevin shell yeah i'm
told like initially people like
to punch you in the face i get that all
the time the time too
yeah i know you have a very punchy
way faster uh it like people i feel like
people connect with you way faster and i
think
you're something that's very analytical
you're too analytical for most people
that could be
that's the reason why steven gardner is
like
the first thing when i watch steven
garner i think family man oh yeah it's
just like he just
took a break from hanging out with his
kids and his wife yeah to go and film a
10 minute video upload it and you know
he's right back
he's got a big heart that's that's what
i think when i think steven gardner
um and then clear value tax is such a
character
it's it's just a character it's like
this guy he's just he gets angry
sometimes he sounds frustrated when he's
talking about nancy pelosi it's just
nancy pelosi and it's just though just
this whole demeanor
it's it's kind of like it makes you want
to you feel it
yeah with you you don't it's you don't
feel it when you talk about nancy pelosi
it's just
no it's just it's analytical it's just
the facts
that's really what it comes down to it's
just yeah i could see that
and yeah that demographic is smaller
than people who just want facts i think
your demographic is very smart they're
very educated
people um but they're very analytical
yeah maybe uh i i you know
i haven't figured myself out yeah that's
that's one thing i
i realize is whatever it's almost
it feels like every year i look back at
myself i'm like i was an idiot last year
what's that like never stops if you're
continually thinking that what you did
the previous year is something different
you've changed it sounds like you're
figuring yourself out
like the whole optimism thing is crazy
because now you get to put like a
positive spin on everything that seems
like
the best kind of progress that you can
have it's it's um
it's made me happier uh and i'll i'll
never forget being in
in high school and i was uh i did speech
and debate in high school so
i was giving i was doing a debate and my
finishing
argument and this was going to like take
home the win on this debate i was having
with with this person i was like totally
big rivals with
uh was uh i started talking there was
some sort of optimism argument that i
had
and so i put it to the class and
surveyed this class of like 40 debaters
like
who here's more optimistic more often
than they are pessimistic
i got like five votes 35 out of the 40
people
were like no i'm i generally look at the
cup half
empty verse half full and and that's
when
like that has stuck with me since then
and i think possibly maybe that's why
the clear value
has that and i'm not saying he looks at
the cup half empty but i think that
appeals to that demographic yes
yeah yeah because it's that anger that
incitement
is is powerful i think that's what you
see with news media now today cnn is
trying to incite anger fox trying to
incite anger yeah
that is just human nature that's how
we're wired i think so
it takes it robs happiness because we
are more risk-averse than we are willing
to
take a risk to gain yes right right yes
because we're scared of what could
happen yes of course
same with a lot of our video title i
mean it's a lot of it is negative it's
right is the market about to crash
index funds there you go 100 it's uh
negativity cells
uh and what do they say negativity
travels seven times as fast as possible
why not play into that my whole thing is
you could play into the negativity with
the headline but
you could turn around the perception in
the video because if
i said say real estate's going up ten
percent next but
no one watches that no one watch it dude
they get no value from it
on the other hand is real estate market
about to collapse sure
ten times the amount of views and in the
video you explain your reasoning so that
by the end of it you're like okay now i
feel comfortable
so it's it's you acknowledge human
psychology yes and then you have
once you're there you have an effort to
change perception yeah
yeah i i think almost every youtuber has
to almost do that
uh you know i think with there there are
certain niches and youtube that can get
away with not having to do any of that
specifically probably tech you know you
show something on a thumbnail you don't
you don't have to necessarily be super
negative unless you disagree with that
no that's the same foldable phone
everything was negative those are all
trending
yeah okay all right i think it tests the
problem with tesla oh
my regrets
wouldn't you rather know if you're about
to buy this camera what's wrong with the
camera
first or
i'll do my first tech review on that one
right there yeah we could try to turn
that one back on
i know you're right otherwise it's like
if everything's fine with it you get
what you pay for fine it's boring but
what's wrong well that's
it's that's an interesting almost just
uh human nature thing that i i think you
brought up very well
that uh yeah yeah that's that's the
thing about life though
i think just going to that original
question though what brings happiness i
think that probably answers it for me
is optimism
not relative and uh and providing for
other people
you know providing jobs and security for
other people but
uh you know you did bring up cardone
should we talk about that
yeah ask me some questions oh man
what so you made a video on him
no i i've i've yeah i think you've told
me
a year ago a long time ago probably
you've told me yeah
this is what we tell this is our
campfire here
gather the kids around and tell a spooky
story
for halloween that time uncle g
oh see kevin speaking of which do you
know
that he's supposed to be on undercover
billionaire
wow yeah he's the next undercover
billionaire where's my are you serious
yeah yeah yeah
he's uh and uh wow rumor has it
no sources to be sourced here uh rumor
has it
he uh covid uh kind of hurt the outcome
and so now they're trying to delay
posting it or like the cardone camp's
trying to delay getting it out
uh because they they don't want the
result to be what it is now
so what's under what what's undercover
billionaire what is this because i'm
thinking like undercover jobs like where
they're going behind
it's a discovery channel show they they
did one with uh it was he was a really
good guy
i don't remember who it was but they did
a whole season where basically they give
someone a hundred bucks and a cell phone
and they're like oh you know go start a
business or whatever
yeah yeah it's a great concept but he
actually
somewhere he has an instagram
that has like uh 150 followers
on his his starting new account and
uh 150. oh yeah because nobody knows
about this yet right
uh but yeah it's funny because i made so
many cardone exposed videos
uh i get i i get all the hits on cartoon
it's hilarious
uh you know the instagram i do know the
instagram no i'll gladly shout it out i
don't care i mean good for him i think
it's awesome he got on that i just can't
figure out what it is now
uh there's got to be a way i could go to
followers i got 138 it's got to be one
of these
uh so i'll find it okay but uh but yeah
you know i i have to give cardone credit
because he gave me plenty of content to
make plenty of videos from
your biggest videos back then were grant
cardone exposed videos or just exposed
videos in general
yes and i remember those would take you
about a week to do
research and film you would post and it
would just be an
instant hit i mean i remember back then
you were getting like 20 000 views the
first hour
which back then for your channel that
would be the equivalent of me getting
like
500 000 views in an hour the first hour
relative to the subscribers
the subscribers yes just these videos
just took off
and would get hundreds of thousands of
views again it would be like me getting
10 million views on a video
i wonder if he blocked me because i
can't find him anymore i wouldn't be
surprised because he blocked me on the
other one
okay then i'd have to go in my mind what
did you do to grant her down
oh well i think all the videos probably
did oh i found him
real luis curtis there he is
see look at that real luis curtis and
then hey look at that look at the
followers 252
what was the point of this i think this
was his undercover
uh billionaire see there his name's
pueblo
and you'll have to put these pictures on
screen this is him with the covered mask
back on july 19th
uh there's this undercover look with the
the glasses they gave him and so they
just had they set him out and he's got
to make money now
yeah and i think he made some marketing
business or something like that
well that's and and i don't know this
but the root yes he will work for a
million dollars
and as a sign or like i don't know
whatever these silly things he's got out
here
uh i haven't looked down okay uh yeah no
so somebody uh somebody reached out and
said just uh
you know and hey just fyi
like i know this is happening uh here's
the
instagram and that's crazy to have those
connections like no one would find that
ever and to know someone who's in on
that
to message you and you see all this it's
pretty remarkable
it's it's weird though uh but yeah i
mean i think probably i shouldn't have
delivered flowers to his office
let me explain it because you were
circling what you did yes you made
many videos many a video like four
amazing
yeah grant cardone that was you made 40
at least
it was a lot i would say less than 10.
no uh there's a lot of videos they all
got such good views well
that's the thing you sometimes if you do
one video
and people love it and they're and i
remember back then people were
literally commenting on my channel can
you expose grant cardone
could you like they already knew what it
was but can you expose him
could you expose him so anyway you made
a lot of videos on grant cardone
and for what was it uh april fool's or
no no it was uh
christmas christmas 20 was it night if
you wanted to fly to
florida and deliver flowers to his
office and you rented a whole
big u-haul truck you bought like two
thousand dollars of the flowers
poinsettia
flowers that's right dress dissolves in
a santa with a megaphone
um to deliver and i told you not to do
it i said it was a bad idea but
but that was a point too uh uh we were
hanging out with danny duncan
and i think you got the inspiration from
danny duncan to be like just pulling
some silly little prank
i said don't do it we're not danny
duncan we can't do that so you flew to
florida
and you filmed this video and i told you
you sent it to me and i remember being
in vegas gambling yeah walking into yeah
i was i was at like at the crap stable
you send me this video i stepped aside i
watch it like don't post it
don't post a video like five minutes
later goes live
and i remember watching the video it's a
bad idea
uh the whole thing went wrong you pushed
the boundaries
grant cardone sued for trespassing you
went through an expensive lawsuit
you won then i told you don't post about
the
lawsuit that you won and you did post
about the lawsuit that you won
and then he sues you again for something
else
and uh i'm like just don't post this
time about winning and you didn't post
that time so anyway but that's not the
only one
there's another one i we won't talk
about the other one but there's someone
else who can't be named
also sued you for um you know it's a
touchy one but
another personal finance person we'll
put it that way i won't i can bleep it
so how much were both of those lawsuits
how much does that cost you
well so uh i think to back up a tiny bit
you're right there was a time that
uh i was very interested in hey
let's like let's do the the kevin in the
wilderness
prank style videos uh and and that's
very common not in the finance space at
all that's very common in in the other
spaces
and i had gone to the uh what's that
house called where mr beast did the uh
circle challenge
oh it was it was no it was a hype house
and then before that it was a phase
house right
yeah uh and i think uh probably a little
overexposed to the whole idea of pranks
and challenges
uh korea well we could do this in
finance uh and so that led to
uh what i thought were creative ideas uh
to to create a point
but uh obviously uh not all ideas work
out
that is something that uh one of my
flaws
is i will try something uh even if it
has a good chance of failing
and and i admit that that's that's a
failure
there are there are a lot of times in my
life where i look yeah
i've done two steps forward one step
back i probably could have
been in a much better place if i didn't
do some of those one step backs
fortunately i will say uh both of the
lawsuits
uh you know yeah while they they
probably cost 150
000 uh tax write-off
it's over i didn't lose uh
they're gone well see for to
well the cardone ones were a joke
because they they i got sued for
stalking not trespassing stalking
yeah yeah and they used to they used the
youtube videos to suggest that i was a
stalker
but that doesn't work uh and so
then they said okay well we have two
instances where kevin personally stalked
me
and in one of the instances cardone
wasn't even there
and so the judge is like you got nothing
uh so that was nicely thrown out so that
was easy but
the way the legal system works in
america is and this is something to take
away
is if you get sued and you don't have a
contract
there's something called the american
rule that says you're responsible for
your own legal
fees so he has an in-house legal counsel
who gets paid a salary no matter what
because it's a domestic violence lawsuit
he doesn't have
filing fees at the court uh so he gets
to file a lawsuit for free
no extra charges with his attorney to
try to make my life miserable
i pay 40 or 50 grand uh
def getting to in front of a judge to
where they dismiss the lawsuit
and i'm stuck with i'm stuck with the
bill i'm stuck paying my
part so yeah i mean there's there's
something where
uh now when people ask me for example
which i get all the time they're like
kevin
should should i have an lsc that's
probably the most common question i get
is i need an llc i need an llc i need an
llc you're going to start a 3d
matterport business gotta have an lc
you're going to be an agent gotta have
an lc you can have real
real estate got mlc it's bull it does
nothing for you uh what does good for
you is insurance
proper insurance if you're doing the
stuff i was doing media insurance is a
good idea
if you know you're a landlord proper
umbrella policies and things like that
but uh you know i've been in depositions
and uh
i have an s corporation does nothing for
you unless you're ready to have
a professional cpa who knows everything
about your books and your company and
handles the books for your company who
could testify and know
everything about your company and then
forensic accountants who are able to
corroborate and be able to
separate bankrupt that company and just
let it go or let it go bk
yeah it's it's worthless so
uh the life lessons that i've learned
from those
i think have been profitable or will be
profitable in the long term
so i'm excited about that wanna switch
cameras
so they seem pretty expensive but uh
they also seem worthwhile those life
lessons
every failure i've had from meet and
done which lost me like 200 grand
to the lawsuits or being an idiot in
school
or or doing goofy things because even
though and
that's one of my problems my fatal flaws
i feel like is i will get told from a
million people don't do it don't do it
don't do it and i will just do it
anyway because i had to and nothing's
changed when i was 16 i was told
you're going on too many ride alongs
with with law enforcement
you can only go on a ride along one day
a week
i was so pissed i went in at 12 a.m
midnight
and i did the night shift and the day
shift in the same day
so i got two ride alongs and they were
so pissed because i got that it was one
day
you like pushing the boundaries that's
all
it always comes back to that because you
will never listen unless you learn
yourself the hard way yes yes yes uh and
and i admit that's a flop but uh i still
do no you say it's a flaw but at the
same time if you've learned such
so many things expensive lessons yeah
they're expensive but at the same time
you said it would probably prove worthy
at some point in the future like i think
it already roi
on those expensive lessons i i would say
even just
um from a happiness point of view the
the roi return has been endless because
i've
experienced so many different things and
failed in so many ways
that i can really look at the successes
and go
i'm happy and that's that's really
helpful so it's almost like
if i only had successes without failures
it wouldn't be as good
i don't know so it's not so much a
shortcoming anymore no no i look back at
every stupid thing i've done
and and i just laugh about it but you're
also it's good for you because i know
that there are definitely people out
there that have failures
and then they spin it in a way to where
they like can't use that failure to be
productive or
grow in the future but you obviously
you're able to use these failures
that you've had and turn them into
learning experiences and that's also
that's not something everyone can do
yeah
i mean i don't know maybe maybe maybe
they're just some failures you can't
learn
that are just like i'm an idiot right
that was really dumb that's true you
know
but uh but hey you know if you can make
the best of everything
it thinks the day goes by happier uh and
there are days that i freak out like you
know when would like because
the way i've set up my studio and you
were asking me i think during a break is
like
why why did i spend 150 000 on my studio
and so that when i walk in there
everything's perfect just i don't have
to set up anything i push a couple
buttons and i start filming
uh and there are those times where it's
like something goes wrong and i'm like
oh
like that frustration comes over but uh
ev everything i've i'm what i'm trying
to do is just systemize
every part of my life where like been
there don't need to do that again been
there don't need it again
and i'm always trying to find where's
that just that left lane on the highway
where i could set autopilot and go
and that's almost kind of that groove
that i feel like i'm in right now okay
there's a real estate deal great we've
got the formula for it
okay this is a new breaking news topic
all right we're gonna do the thumbnail
first we got our clapper ready
uh you know we got what we're gonna wear
you gotta have the clapper
uh you know i didn't i don't got any
face powder but i gotta get some face
powder on
and uh you're good to go you know uh see
i run
really hot too people always wonder like
why are you always wearing a jacket
it's because my studio is 65 degrees
it's like
80 in here dude i'm dying oh
you asked me what i like about the
difference between here and the place
we're from yeah i mean here it's so hot
all the really yes probably 10 degree
difference the time
that's fine that's why i'm wearing a
dragon i'm totally fine oh my gosh i'm
hot in here
well hey well venturan's here but uh
it's 90 in here we have the ac on yeah
you don't have ac yeah
it's set at 73 because it's colder
outside than it is inside oh my god
that's funny you said you run it at like
67. that's what we run in
our placement yeah as well oh no oh no
no
it's nice no no no no no no 73 with the
last night it was kind of cold
you know well everybody's different
that's the other thing too and that's
one thing that i mean like i have three
air conditioners in my office and
in the studio uh and i freeze it out
lauren comes like i'm not going in there
it's too cold i'm like good don't touch
anything
freeze everybody out of there uh but uh
yeah finding finding those those systems
and then when things
you know the funny thing or maybe it's
not even the funny thing just the
coolest thing about
our world is you know when you're doing
something
right and you know when you're doing
something wrong you do something wrong
oh you get sued you you do something
right
oh the views go up i keep doing more of
that right all right so you make
a lot of stimulus content now do you get
bored
of making stimulus i don't i really
enjoy it
at least one a day right and my goal is
if i could do one stem one real estate
one stock video a day
perfect like you have a shortened
name for it sure oh yeah i found it once
you started doing two stimulus updates a
day
um everything so i need my morning
update
where my stimulus is and then my evening
update how do you do that like
where do you get all the news from to be
able to come up with this like
information at least 10 minutes of
talking points i
i think that almost goes back to uh high
school because
i we the debate style that i did was
called student congress
and so it was it's all reading it was
i get four newspapers delivered i have
every new subscription there is
and i'm i read to the end of these
articles to really understand like every
perspective possible and then i could
try to put this together into okay this
is what's really going on between the
lines
because every reporter has their own
spin too you read the washington post
they're left here you know people are
like the new york times is way left the
new york times is way less left than the
washington post and then you start
noticing where the biases are
okay politico's slightly left right the
economist kind of in the middle the
financial times they're a little left
you go to fox they're obviously much
more on the right you know you go to the
tax foundation a little right
and you start noticing these differences
and then you tie them together and it's
like oh okay i can see a perspective
here that i could share
uh and i i love that i love that
so how many minutes or hours would you
say you read of news every single day
ah you know in terms of news i'm
probably reading okay where do you get
it what sites
what's nice no don't say everything
where's your sources reddit
no that's one thing i don't use i mean
it's mostly i go to the
the you got to go to like the secondary
pages of the big sites
so tell us some sites so wall street
journal new york times
the post uh you know the financial times
amazing content
uh but i'll even read foreign affairs uh
these all these boring things that
nobody reads the economists and stuff
like that
i have this weird thing where i like
reading all that boring stuff and then
just condensing it
into something how much time do you
spend every day reading reading is most
of it see
like the filming and editing is fast i
edit my videos in about five minutes
you've been you posted your video your
income breakdown we need a title for
this video your income breakdown you
make
thousand dollars a day yeah yeah that's
so there were that added hours i'll be
transparent with this
uh i don't think i've told you this uh
there were two
i shouldn't say this uh there we can
believe anything
no no it's no we're gonna leave it in
yeah uh
there were two months this year that i
crossed seven figures
yeah seriously investing though right no
wait
how yeah oh my that's something i've
always wanted to do
[Laughter]
yeah um so yeah it's uh
it's been uh it's been a ride so what do
you what do you do with that
where does it go all real estate all
really with the exception of stocks in
the meantime let's talk about taxes for
example
the seven figures how does that how is
that divided up like because i know that
you're
yeah adsense like i i mean adsense
almost hit 300k yeah what are your
courses
i'm curious courses because you plug the
courses a lot um
well i would say probably uh and i have
a lot of them
uh and i think that helps but uh
you know if if i can consistently be
you know three four a day that's awesome
but that's great taxes yeah how much are
you gonna pay in taxes this year
yeah um well
ideally very little and that's the
hardest thing this is i've actually just
recently been kind of thinking about why
is it
why really why is it that donald trump
doesn't want to show his tax returns
i personally believe it's because there
are so many real estate loopholes to
take such
advanced depreciation on on buildings
and you just continue to purchase
buildings
that you continuously as somebody who's
a full-time real estate investor
or real estate uh what do they call a
professional licensed real estate broker
you get to take all of these extra
losses that normally people can't take
this this camera battery died oh we'll
flip it on really quick um
jack would you mind turning that one off
so once wait let's just finish this this
thing
um so you're saying then that
his tax return is so intricate and he's
got so many deductions and write-offs
and figured out so many loopholes that
the average person would not be able to
decipher that and just see
the net and be like he's not making as
much money as we think he is
he is probably getting tax refund checks
and i think that would make people who
see trump as a billionaire
i'm not not trying to get political here
but i think that would
destroy uh people's perceptions
and i think that would be a very
damaging to the brand that's supposed to
be this this mega
you know income brand but i mean the
reality is
that's that's the way business works
almost that's the
that's almost how these tax laws are
written is uh you get uh for example
you know take cardone for example he's
gonna have zero income taxes for two
years on probably 20 million dollars a
year of income because he bought a plane
for 40.
you know 40 mil brilliant uh is just
eradicated
uh you know all these taxes that you
have to pay and now you have an amazing
marketing tool
it's brilliant uh and he markets himself
as a billionaire using other people's
money
brilliant uh but uh yeah the taxes i
mean
the plain example yeah so my
understanding with that is you buy let's
say a 50 million dollar plane
now you could write off let's say you
make 10 million dollars a year buy a 50
million dollar plane
you're able to write off that entire
cost of the plane in the first year yeah
as a business right off and then carry
those extra four million dollar losses
into the following four years yeah
absolutely i mean
now but the other thing is that when you
sell the plane you'll pay
taxes on that capture unless you could
maybe find a way to 1031 that plan can
you 1031 a plane
all you have to do sure because all you
have to do is buy a new plane
and then write that one off right
yeah but when you sell the old plane
yeah yeah
so because now you have this entirely
new deduction again coming in
on your new purchase uh so no way
so let's say i write up 50 million on a
plane yep zero cost basis zero dollars
for 20.
sell it for 20. now i go and buy a new
plane
for 60. don't i pay recapture
sure on that 20 on the 20 but now you're
running on buying it
so you have to keep buying more
expensive planes of course but think
about how brilliant that is
because that's how they're getting
american industry moving
like you would what they don't want is
you to make a lot of money and do
nothing
you get taxed out the butt uh in and
that's by design
what they want is okay you've been
successful you've made a lot of money
now we want you to look at the tax code
and figure out where your deductions
well where are deductions for kevin
kevin your real estate professional go
buy a ton of real estate hear all the
deductions
why can't someone craft something that
people could buy
in million dollar increments they could
be a 100 tax write-off that have value
that you could 10 31
because my thought is this for for
people that don't know you could buy a
vehicle
what is it the section 179 deduction so
if a vehicle weighs more than six
thousand pounds
uh in the first year you could write off
bonus depreciation of a hundred percent
so a tesla model x is one of those
things that you could buy
the first year is a hundred thousand
dollars you write off the full amount of
your income
why isn't someone going and creating a
million dollar vehicle
let's say this seven thousand pounds but
it's lined with gold or precious
metal or something that has intrinsic
value
so sure you're buying this vehicle but
what it's actually comprised of is gold
there's something like investment or
something right or that
cars price is pegged to the us dollar
just something like that it doesn't even
need to move
just some vehicle tank that you could
say can drive a foot
and you buy that 100 for business use
but that vehicle has a value that you
could then
retain at any point and get loans
against
for income why hasn't someone created
that yet well i think that's the art
industry
because you can buy something for 20
grand get it appraised for 50
right i mean you're writing off your
expenses right but there there are
uh art so i looked into this because i
wanted to
so i don't know how much i'm supposed to
say here but i wanted to buy a picasso
and i looked into it
so i looked into this of spending like
two three hundred thousand dollars on a
piece of art
unfortunately art has it because in
order to depreciate something it has to
degrade over time and that's the gray
area apparently
art if kept in the right condition will
not
degrade or will not lose value so
that does not pass the test to be able
to be depreciated
in in the first year for business use
unfortunately
it has to have wear and tear unless it's
a full write-off
what unless you hung it up in your
office and it's like no no even if you
hang it up in your office it has to have
wear and tear for depreciation but i'm
just wondering can you just can you is
it could it just be deemed a business a
marketing expense
this is a picasso in a real estate
office it brings people in
business expense it's all expensive well
then you get in the point of you could
argue whatever you want yeah it's up to
the irs to decide whether or not that's
that's true we lost one oh jack do you
want to
that's that's the argument there in
terms of the irs yeah and i think that's
that's the big thing is um and there's
also this balance of like
of like fairness too because you want to
pay taxes too in some sense to give back
to the society that enabled but
on the flip side when you're you're
fortunate and you have a really good
year or whatever
yeah i mean to me i look at well i mean
i'm creating jobs i'm
investing in real estate i'm improving
neighborhoods or whatever i mean you
could justify it in any way you want
but the real estate tax deductions that
exist are absolutely insane
uh we were just talking about this the
cost segregation the upfront
especially the donald trump uh attacks
uh law in 2017 that went into effect
that like doubles some of the things
that you can take it's unbelievable
it's unbelievable uh so that's why this
year i'm at uh i'm on my 11th property
this year
for purchasing what's your total amount
of properties
uh 20. we just hit we're going to close
our 20th
gosh man you don't have a management
company or anything it's lauren
lauren does it wow yeah but there's
surprisingly not that much to do once we
renovate them
because like actually when i sat down
over here i saw an email that was copied
to lauren about
uh fourplex that we just bought and uh
this is a property that we did not
renovate because we got all the tenants
with it
so we had an email like stove's broken
it doesn't stress me out though because
i look at it
like no problem like we get a sofa you
know
550 bucks and have it installed for 125
bucks and it's done
the other one's gone uh i enjoy that i
i like those things like no problem
tenant you're getting a new stainless
steel how about that
you know people love that do people know
who you are
your tenants uh we try not to we try to
prevent that
they i mean if they looked at my website
probably i've got to come up with like a
dba or something like that to avoid that
but uh we are always the managers
we try to keep a step back have you had
a tenant who's going to be like hey
where's my stimulus check man i have had
tense follow me on instagram
so okay that's when you know that's when
you know yeah
uh but you know really i think uh the
tenants are uh
you know just you give them a good
product and they're happy people
you know i think if you give a tenant a
lemon because there are landlords who do
that
they will literally they'll buy a
property the way it is and they'll put a
tenant and they'll say you know what
let's just treat this like adults you
just take care of everything
and the landlord doesn't want to do
anything they get frustrated over
everything and they never renovated it's
like what do you expect
you know uh and i think that's when you
really start having problems
uh which is really one of the reasons i
rated going back to this y rated cardone
because he's always talking down
starting small and buying the single
family house so then i got tackled in
his office
you got tackled in his office yeah
how'd you get into his office well
so the part that you didn't mention in
your flower delivery story
trying to make it nice trying to make
you look good uh yeah right
the part you didn't mention the flower
delivery story uh was
um we deliver the flowers outside
and uh i i decided to
to go in their back door and run over to
their sales staff and let them know that
we had delivered flowers
so i ran to the back as an elf uh
thanking them for what they do and
saying that we delivered them flowers
and then as i'm standing there with the
microphone and these people are like
this is like a nice young man delivering
us flowers and then all of a sudden
boom that's bad i'll never forget those
things
i enjoyed that i am like looking i
enjoyed getting tackled
looking back i lo like you can't pay for
those memories
i can't pay for for the unexpected
tackle you know is it a security guard
yeah
but he see he was following santa around
the whole plan was that i was not santa
and so he was following santa around the
front where we were passing out the
flowers and that's how i ran in the back
did you ever meet grant cardone i met
him once at uh what was the event
driven driven driven before at the
starbucks or was this afterwards
before and did you say hello yeah video
with him
yeah he uh uh you know he shook my hand
and said i get it man you know but
if you step on someone's d don't expect
to be able to work with him in the
future and he's right
he's 100 right would you ever consider
buying a cameo from him
buying a cameo oh like him pop up in a
video
he's on cameo he's on you know the app
cameo i don't oh is that phone call
no no it's basically like this platform
where celebrities celebrities
i should do that you should celebrities
like a lot of people youtubers baseball
players
every kind of celebrity yeah they
basically just say hey
send me a message and i'll read it and
i'll take a video of myself and i'll
give it to you
i signed up i signed up for the cameo i
put my info in let's see if they really
yeah so that would be fun do you know
who uh will the financial wolf is
he's a smaller finance channel he bought
a cameo from grant cardone
and he sent me the video yeah it's just
grant cardone like hey
you got this will keep working hard or
whatever yeah
oh that's funny how much was like 500 no
it's
300 300 300 bad at all to get a
personalized video from grant cardone
myself yeah 30 60 second video
yeah i've seen them before it's usually
like hey man doing well
keep it up congratulations
you know stuff like that he could do
that for you
congratulations man almost at one
million good job on the single families
i specifically want you to endorse
single families
i don't know it's
you know what it what i will say about
youtube is it's been
fun uh and and there are there are times
when you look and it's like it's a grind
but uh it's it's a different world and
that's why i always encourage just like
go do it go start making videos and
putting stuff out there and
like your audience tells you if it's
good or not yeah like i showed you
before i did my my finance channel i had
a very brief stint of just doing like
family vlog videos
and uh i i did the same stupid stuff
and i crashed to vidcon uh which danny
duncan
danny duncan had done that the year
before danny duncan had crashed vidcon
by pretending to be a security guard
so i snuck into all the backstage events
at vidcon
and then made a video about it and got
banned
[Laughter]
so it sounds like honestly you would
rather or at some point do prank videos
just do funny i would love that uh that
would be
that would be uh just the way don't you
ever just try one out of context
try another prank you know i think with
the last ones i got
sued for i don't know
you could do it yeah i'm not gonna say
it don't give me ideas
i i it would just at this point i'd have
to like put a mustache on and or let's
just like shave just and just have a
mustache i guess
and and just do a different channel
that would be funny to start a different
channel yeah tell nobody
and just see what happens to it yeah
yeah that would be funny
oh just giving away stuff but you know
the funny thing the crazy thing is a lot
of people are doing that now
you know the the giveaways that's
there's a reason why their people are
doing it yeah but it's not it's not as
it's not as effective every single prank
goes through that phase
yeah remember a while it used to be the
pickup the gold digger pranks
they were effective in their time back
then but not anymore
no or like the giveaway is you know the
lambo pranks
picking up picking up uber riders and
cart those don't work no more
mr beast started the new style of the
big giveaways and the challenges
guarantee two years from now it's gonna
be so saturated
she's probably gonna have to pivot to
something else yeah well he kind of
is in a way like he's just doing huge
like
displays of just like the fireworks or
something like he's doing just
right but i have a feeling he's going to
pivot more towards those big projects or
just crazy stuff that no one else has
the money to do
something i've noticed that he's doing
too is he's now incorporating
multiple challenges within one video so
he hooks you in with one challenge
before he gets to the end of that
challenge he sets the hook for the next
challenge
before you get to the end of that one he
sets the hook for the next challenge
and so you're almost watching the video
not to get to the end result of one
challenge you're watching the whole
video to get to the end of four or five
challenges yeah like the fireworks
it's a perfect example of starting off
with like okay so we got
a five hundred dollar firework a hundred
dollar firewall a thousand dollars and
then all the way up to this like crazy
finale right it works though yeah
because if the whole video was just
we're going to light up this crazy
firework is a vlog
and in the last 30 seconds if it people
just
scroll past yes last 30 seconds he's
smart it's very smart it's very smart
and you had mentioned like what about
what happened to the kevin about like
jumping out of the bushes and all that
kind of stuff
uh i those videos took a lot of time and
effort like you said i was posting you
know once or twice a week
and uh too niche maybe just not there's
like no traction in this craziness
whereas uh the news perspective i really
enjoy and they're easy to do
told you yeah you did yeah you did
wow what you got to do next you heard it
here first is you're going to start a
network
and you're going to get a few other
people you're gonna get someone else's
network
i will not you're gonna no you're gonna
get somebody
else dude there's there's there's a lot
in that
you're gonna get somebody else to cover
other topics that
you yourself cannot cover like
makeup whatever there's a huge market
for that there's a huge market
find somebody else i think who's as good
as you are
but just needs a little direction really
that's all you got to do
and get them to to cover some other
topic that you would not cover
yeah and you could slowly start your own
network of news
the problem is and this maybe i'm just
jaded and i want to hear what you say
about this
one of the things that i've distanced
myself from that i love
is is not no offense jack
not having employees uh like seriously
not no
that's fair yeah like i've been trying
to distance myself from that too
to do this or something
[Music]
so yeah after meeting done when there
was a point where i had 15 employees i
realized i never wanted that obligation
again like look if you're a painter and
you're looking for work you want to come
work your dry waller like hey you got
work today like hey i got some projects
for you or whatever like you want to do
the 1099 gig
sure but do i want to go back to having
to meet payroll every week
you know that stress is crazy i'll worry
that it would almost be like that
or why wouldn't they just go out on my
on their own you know why why need me
after a while
you know oh it's totally good oh yeah
okay we got a plug for
for yada bank have you ever seen this
yet i thought you know but by the time
this video comes out my video will have
come out so i could talk about it oh the
because you mentioned that in the kevin
o'leary thing the the fintech thing
that's this
you're doing yada tomorrow yeah yeah so
guys
sign up with the link in the description
below helps me out a lot
let me know your thoughts on this this
is a company i invested in yeah the bank
this is this is the one this is the one
so i signed up for this
about a month and a half ago ask sebby
made a video on i watched all of his
videos and he called it the best high
interest savings account
and when he posted that video i realized
like i had gotten dozens of comments
from people saying review yada bank
review yana bank
and i've never heard of it before but
when everyone comments something and i
see a video on i'm like going to take
notice
ask subby made a review on this and what
it is it's his prize link savings
account
so instead of just paying you a set
interest rate like allied bank is 0.6
percent
what yada bank does is they pay you 0.2
percent but
then you can earn prizes let me show you
this
so what you do for every one dollar you
save
you get one ticket and
you can see here every day they draw a
new number
and so if you match the yada number you
get 10 cents if you match your number in
this you get 15
all the way up to 10 million dollars if
you match every number plus the yada
number you can also win a tesla 5
1500 and ask sebi
actually did the math and calculated the
odds of winning
or the odds of earning money from this
depending on how many tickets you have
and he calculated that the average
interest rate that you would earn from
this
is somewhere around three three and a
half percent
so i figured if i could make on average
three and a half percent on this or
point eight percent of the time on ally
bank i may as well throw some money on
this so i put seventy thousand dollars
in this app
just to try it out and the second week
i won i think it was like i earned like
300 bucks or something like that it was
like 260 something
and so i sent a text to ask semi saying
like wow this is amazing
so far my average interest rate is like
six something per seven percent or
whatever
so sebby said it's funny because i've
been in
in contact with the owner of this
company and
i invested in it would you be interested
so of course i look up this guy
on online and i look him up on facebook
and then we have like mutual friends
from high school believe it or not
wow and so i talked with adam
and we talk about like his goals and and
what he wants to do with this
and i started researching the psychology
behind a prize-linked savings again this
is really big in other countries
in the uk they have what's called a
premium bond
which is instead of paying an interest
rate random people are selected to
win very large prizes so like a million
pounds
so imagine you put in you put in a
thousand dollars in a premium bond
your money is guaranteed you're always
going to get your thousand dollars back
but that enters you
to win a million pounds in the uk
people would much rather earn
nothing on their money but have the
small chance of earning a million pounds
than they would
earning let's say half a percent at the
very
best on their money so that takes this
now in the united states what i found
interesting was that price link savings
accounts
were not allowed into until 2015
when they were legalized wow so now it's
this whole new world of pricing savings
account where
in almost every other country that this
was introduced this increased savings
rates
because more people like the small
chance of having the potential to earn
all the way to 10 million think about if
if you had
if you had 500 bucks yeah would you
rather earn
two dollars a year on that money
or would you rather earn no two dollars
a year but have the small chance
every single week at earning 10 million
it makes sense what you're saying
yes so psychology so i looked into this
i liked
where they're heading with this and i
figured why not i may as well i
liked the app enough where like before
any of this i was like macy sign up for
this jack sign up for the like my dad
signed him
like i had everyone signed up because i
liked it so much what so
what um what did you invest into it
i can't say you tell kevin i could tell
kevin just bleep this out
are they promising a return no okay
but what's it what's it pegged to then
just
so it's their first real round of
funding so they passed y combinator
yeah and this is their first round of
funding
no they closed it yeah yeah wow
interesting so i get
uh a small piece of that and then i also
have uh
other parts of equity that could vest
well to double that
that's interesting yeah yeah crazy yeah
wow um it's interesting maybe what are
you what do you want to ask sebby
yeah what do you think uh yeah uh the
problem with me
is uh and this is nothing against that
that at all i think that's a phenomenal
model because i mean that's why we play
the lottery
uh i don't personally but as a society
why we play lottery
uh i i'm just not a big saver
uh you know i think that's something
that that you uh definitely have over me
is i'm all in on tesla i'm all in on
real estate
i keep myself cash poor to the point
where
sometimes like i wake up i'm like bank
balance is negative 5k
oh you got some money from somewhere uh
and that
i do that on purpose uh i don't
purposely overdraw you're
pending you can move money and you don't
pay the fees right but
uh i do that on purpose because it it
keeps me always working in a weird way
so it's almost like oh
gotta work because i'm out of cash okay
but yeah there's a big difference
between
you who's earning tens of thousands of
dollars almost a day
and the average person who's like can't
can't come up with five hundred dollars
for an emergency
that that that's who this app
the general people is is targeting the
eighty percent
ninety percent it's it's it's and and
which is an interesting business model
because i was asking
adam and i was saying isn't it more
profitable to go after the high net
worth
clients why not because ucp
big banks like jp morgan are going after
the high net worth individuals
right bank of america high net worth
wells fargo is trying to get more of
their premier clients with like a
million dollars or more in liquid
they want those people because those are
that's where the money is
but recently a lot of these online banks
have been going after
not those people you're going after the
people who barely have anything
and i was i was you know very interested
in that but um
but that's where i don't say more
opportunity lies but that's where
there's
just just more room to grow and yeah and
people
don't have any savings and need some
sort of incentive to save more money
i can believe that uh and hey you know
if people initially start saving more
money and they're incentivized to
ins uh well to save then then finally
they could get into real estate
which i think is where the real money is
and that's a different i mean obviously
it's not an investment i would never say
invest in
this prize savings account but in south
africa it was uh it was found that
it increased savings rates substantially
once they introduced this
people started saving money for the
first time technology
yeah i believe it i i believe it no
that's something yeah and the
interesting thing too is is my money in
there my
70 grand i i don't want to take it out
because it's like it's
it's having that small chance of being
like well you never know and the average
interest rate is higher than la bank so
i'm like i may as well just
don't do this link down below in the
description you get an extra 100 tickets
you know you you could just
yolo it all on tesla options though yeah
but then i risk it
i'd rather a guaranteed two percent
three percent in this fair
fair okay okay well that's cool
yoda yoda bank yada yada okay so yada i
actually thought was a
horrible name and i inquired i'm like
why is this tall diana but i think yada
there's an old song
that went viral and this is like back
2001 is a yata
this is why yada bank will fail
wow single-handedly we'll take it out
yeah they got 7.3 million views with 1
000 subscribers
it's catchy all right yeah oh my gosh
it's gonna be stuck in your head forever
now we'll probably only put a clip in
that but uh
yeah apparently yada is um 10
to the power of 24. uh that is a yada
that's a yada number oh wow okay wow
wow oh my gosh well well good for you
on uh investing in uh in fintech
yeah first of all congratulations you
would see that like kevin o'leary said
50 50 chance writing that whole thing
off it's either going to be a zero
you probably will yeah uh chime bank
recently got a valuation of now fifteen
point eight
billion no they didn't china are you
serious shine
bank online banks are about to take over
for reference bank of america is valued
at 200
billion dollars bank of america
it's gonna switch i guarantee no one
in 30 years from now is going to use
bank of america or wells fargo
chase i believe in i think they're a
good enough bank but other one like ally
bank
chime these just these these internet
they're going to take over so my thing
if i can get in
yada bank early on i mean maybe just
enough who knows but i like the product
a lot
wow wow yeah speaking of kevin o'leary i
don't think he thinks i diversify enough
no he's not what i did not unders why
would he tell you to pay
like to pay down your real estate debt i
think he's coming from the perspective
of someone who has so much money
that it doesn't matter because i've
started to realize too as you earn more
and more and more
the the difference you can make in
leveraging your money becomes less and
less valuable
like to go in and and and borrow money
at three percent to make
five when you're making so much money
elsewhere
it becomes less valuable um
so if for me it was really good in the
beginning when i was trying to like
save every dollar is like oh if i can
get out that extra 10
a month by doing this over here it's
worth it to me
in that growth phase but then when you
get so much money i think it's more
about maintaining and less about growing
sure yeah the payoff face yeah if you
can guarantee to me
i'm gonna grow it five percent a year
every single year
i would take it if that was like a
guarantee
no questions asked next 20 years versus
the possibility
of earning eight percent but you also
have the chance at making two
i picked probably the guaranteed five
sure yeah just or or you know what a
better analogy would be
making three percent or ten percent or
five percent guaranteed i think i would
probably take the five percent guarantee
just knowing that
i have enough all you need to just just
let's grow it sell
everything and invest into 18 t you can
get 7.9 what four percent dividend yeah
well the stock slowly continues to go
down
i bought that a while ago and it stayed
exact it's it's gone down like a dollar
they've just been sitting at 29 to 30
20. it's going down a little bit i got
some short strangles on there
oh my gosh i saw you guys did an options
video and uh that didn't
go well yeah it went amazingly it was a
two out of ten
and also also why don't you sell covered
calls on your tesla
yeah because i don't want to miss the
run-up but you could still be generating
crazy passive income even if you choose
strike prices
way above right now why don't you strike
prices in like a month at
six hundred dollars exactly can we do a
quick calculation of how much you could
be making off-covered calls
sure yeah of course no i i know
uh i mean i'll occasionally do some call
i'll buy calls which i know you only
like writing
uh i i saw that video i know um
one of the things i'll tell you one of
the big reason that i love to just hold
the stocks is because
when i sit on tons of unrealized gains
i'm not paying taxes on okay but that
was also
in kevin o'leary's mind a misstep god
that was dumb in my opinion i i will
bluntly say that that was
kevin o'leary says that that's a good
thing you're paying taxes
no no it's not a good thing you're
paying taxes but he says it was a
mistake because
yes it's like you know when you were up
to 500 which is a pretty arguably like a
pretty ridiculous price for tesla shock
right like half post split
like if you were to sell and realize the
gains yeah
it did have a correction yeah you know
and you could have
accepted the the tax payment yeah but
see
here's the problem that happens once you
unlock the psychology of selling a stock
you sell a stock like graham did at 9.25
and then now you're out of tesla or less
in tesla
and then you sold now your psychology
says well i sold why would i buy in
higher
now you stop buying in at 1100 and 1200.
i never sold instead i just kept buying
at 11 1200 i think his
is more about diversifying about cutting
it off at five
yeah moving to another store and then
rebalancing i see what you're saying
though because
i sold it nine something and i thought
it was a genius when it went down to
like
seven or six yeah and i was intending to
buy back in but i
didn't i bought back in higher than
where i sold it
sure sure yeah no it's one of the things
is looking back is always easy right
with with stocks certainly
but one of the things that i love is uh
not having to worry about taxes is and
if i can just avoid taxation that's fine
if i'm unbalanced
i don't care i don't need the money i
like the
the the what i've chosen to invest in
and i'm willing to invest in that for
the next 10.
yeah and that's why you buy options as
well because selling i'll buy calls
i wanted to i wanted to say this because
there were a few comments and they said
that
selling options is extremely it's a bad
relative to taxes which is totally true
like i totally acknowledge that yeah but
also
you could be selling covered calls on
tesla right and if you're selling
500 strike price november 6 so it's like
40 day theta i don't know how long that
is sure
yeah about 40 30 days that's 20
elections 40 days away so yeah like a
little bit over here
sure no no you me or physically yeah
yeah physically you right you want to
get closer how many shares do you have
uh probably ten thousand no maybe more
uh let's just go with ten thousand two
hundred and thirteen
thousand dollars what a month or a year
in one month
in a month that's a month you can make
200 000 a month so
because if you look here i'll show you
so this is 500
so also you'd be able to sell tesla at
500 per share
which is a hundred more dollars so it's
like a 20 increase in one
month also one could argue that this is
a pretty high price for tesla because
this is where it did its past dip
yeah it's 21.33 cents per share and you
see
you said you had 10 000 shares right
21.33 times
10 thousand so you get to so you do this
it doesn't hit it you get two hundred
and thirteen thousand dollars profit in
one month
or what you could do is if it goes above
it it would have to go up above that
share price five hundred dollars twenty
one dollars and thirty three yeah so for
525 let's say again and
by november then then i lose whatever
gains are above that
exactly but i've also now been forced to
sell my stock yeah
uh and now i've also been forced to sell
unrealized gains on two and a half
million dollars or something like that
that's true so now i'm paying paying a a
1.25 million dollar tax bill that i
wasn't
really paying it's true yeah but what do
you think the chances are the tesla's
gonna get five
twenty five dollars in one month i mean
that's for probably an unlikely chance
that tesla's gonna go from
390 to five yeah but look
go back to the relative election yeah
but be be relative
to what the stock price was i mean uh
what's it at now you know 400 times five
it's two thousand dollars a share we
were just buying tesla
a thousand two months ago you know so uh
especially with a volatile stock like
tesla it's almost one that i almost
certainly don't want to
do the options on now if if you were
saying kevin you got all this money in
18t stock
sell the 50 calls it's never going to
50.
yeah nobody how much how much could you
make off
18 tv let's try that yeah if i had all
my money
no one's 18 no one's selling there's
nothing anyone's let's look what's that
because nobody expects that as a
potential and that's where the market is
option
sure it's unlikely that it'll execute
watch you go to november six
yeah sell a call the highest you're on
buy
so i mean it's the same right so i get a
penny
realistically you could this would be 12
cents on 31
okay so so do that so do uh do five
million dollars
on on 18t in tesla so do five mil
uh but divided by it was like how much
per share is thirty one dollars
it's thirty one dollars yeah or no it
because how many shares you would be
able to buy at
the current price so that'd be like
twenty nine dollars right sure
okay so divided by 29. oh as in how many
shares i would have okay so you'd have
that many 170
divided by 100 because this is how many
contracts you'd be able to buy
so a thousand so multiply that times
six cents or what was it oh i didn't
need to divide by a hundred i can times
by a hundred
because you just be able to use the
because it's multiplying by a hundred
anyway yeah yeah exactly the price um
so like thirty so multiply that times
twelve cents
times point one 20 grand
20 grand every one month
right for 18 t to hit 31.
but this was five million dollars right
yeah so
i mean it makes sense the thing about um
what it is
implied volatility right sure so since
tesla has such a higher iv oh yeah uh
which basically means how likely it will
be to
hit that price exactly so the higher iv
rank there it is
the higher the premiums are so something
like tesla has a really really high iv
rate
yeah some things that can affect iv
would be like earnings reports
or just like obviously fad news or yeah
blowing numbers out of the way yeah out
of the water
yeah i mean that's uh but but the big
thing for me and i really disagree with
kevin o'leary on that i think the taxes
thing is is a terrible mistake i mean
why why would i diversify away from
tesla just to pay the taxes there's 50
percent diversification right there
is giving it to the government to
utilize so many write-offs
right if you were to i mean there's a
limit right i can only buy
so many properties what if what if you
were at your max and then
a new opportunity came up with a new
property and
you could sell those stocks sell you
know put that covered call there and
yeah
you were already maxed out would it make
sense to you then um
so look if there was uh
[Music]
see the the other thing is i then i'm
gonna miss the next run-up
you know and that's the big thing i
think the biggest thing for me that i
that you mentioned psychology of it
because there was a point in my
portfolio where i was up a lot and
boeing
i think i bought in like 128 and went to
230 and i was up a lot
and i was thinking oh should i sell but
then the taxes
and i didn't and now it's down to like
150 something again
i mean obviously hindsight is 20 20. but
it would have made sense
in that situation to pay the taxes even
at 50
uh and just diversify away but
everything is down since then so who
knows but you know but the other thing
there
is one of the things that that i learned
making a mistake was having a strategy
for the stock
so for example i i never want to hold
delta carnival cheesecake dave buster's
my intention is never to hold those
companies for
10 20 years right i don't care about
those companies outside this pandemic
right
uh so for those companies maybe that's
boeing for you maybe that would have
made sense to sell boeing
uh something like tesla apple amazon
etsy redfin i i have no horizon where i
say
i'm i'm ready to sell it and so i'm
willing to just carry those taxes
you know i think that's one place we
differ is i'm a big fan of
how much can i put into like a
retirement account but get a tax
deduction for
as opposed to the roth because i'm
trying to delay the tax bill
which yeah in the future you got to pay
but the future is uncertain
i want to be able to create as much
wealth as i can now
because that's going to you know in my
own compound point
well yeah but you know then you pay
taxes you get compounded taxes i like
knowing that what i have right now is
mine
right that's what i like i like the
peace of mind guess that pay tax on it
i'm good to go but next in real estate
you might never have to pay taxes on it
right so that's that's the flip side so
if i can move money
uh and and like i take margin that's why
i got into the margin
as i take the margin i buy real estate i
never have to buy real estate or margin
i never have to pay taxes on them but
why are you buying so many why don't you
buy one
two big ones instead a whole bunch of
little tiny ones yeah
uh there's a lot of competition for big
units it's insane
uh there's no way you can get a deal on
big units
uh you have to overpay to get big units
and then you hold the units
expecting them to go up in value that's
it yeah the cash flow covers the
expenses maybe you got a little bit of a
you know a three or four percent yield
you're buying in texas or florida or
whatever maybe you got five percent or
something like that
the rest over that it's usually just
magic juju where they delay the fees
until later
like this is something cardone capital
does they go we promise you six percent
they write the six percent checks
but then i i believe at least their
their uh prospectus allows them to do
this
they can actually waive their their
annual one percent management fee
until they sell the property so all of a
sudden you get all of those oh by the
way we didn't bill you for the last 10
years yeah
so so your return effectively is
substantially lower than the six percent
that's advertised especially with like
35
waterfall he does but all that
complicated stuff aside
i love buying these little deals because
you saw the hoarder house you got the
coffee machine you still have a lot of
work
it's right there seriously i use it i
use it every few days you got it yeah
and and people thought that was staged
that was a real
find and that has she had a lot of good
stuff i still believe there's a one
percent chance you've planted
that therefore that's too perfect
because it's i use it every single day
well you have you still think that i
bought instagram followers yes i do
yeah because you said there was a 20
chance that i bought them
yeah that was your belief yes yeah what
was the jump um kevin went from like
what were you at back then
a thousand fifteen hundred fifteen
hundred went to like eleven thousand
within like two
like two days three days yeah and
they're all like bought followers
you couldn't look at them yeah yeah
they're just like from different
countries oh no it was unsubs like crazy
yeah exactly but we suspected that one
of the people i exposed did that so they
could try to make an exposed video on
yes
so yeah uh kevin made an exposed video
on someone else long history man
we've been talking for a long time he
says i don't give them good ideas we
share good ideas okay
the tesla video the come on the 78 tesla
dude
come on man i convinced you to buy a
tesla
no it was jeremy yeah right jeremy
financial education duke that out but
anyway so kevin did an exposed video
and we think that person bought
followers
10 000 to kevin so this person could
then make an exposed video on kevin
saying look he bought these followers
like look at this he went from this to
this overnight look at all the unsubs
yeah this person's talking bad about me
well look at what he just did
sure meanwhile because anyone could buy
fake followers for anybody
yeah wait i don't even know what we're
talking about before the instagram
follower thing i forget
but uh yeah yeah you know it kind of
goes back to the beginning of just the
the
positive mindset i think we were talking
about tesla call options
yeah i ain't doing any taxes kevin
o'leary that's where we were
i disagree with the tax argument
completely
i disagree with his mortgage advice
i think it's a terrible way for people
to start his uh what did he do with the
with the protein versus protein
carbs pasta yeah yeah that's an
old-school mentality in the 80s you know
what
i think it's just because you see these
people who went through
the 80s real estate boom yes it seems
like everybody who went
through that cycle is anti-debt yeah
but you have to think too from their
person like the same people the same
like our
grandparents or whoever went through the
great depression they're just like
we're gonna hoard what we have right now
because you never know we're gonna keep
our cash we don't trust banks
i think if you go through something like
that you might have a different outlook
on things
100 percent i think financing was so
different than too i mean even just in
the last recession people like oh we're
going to have another 07.
you know the financing now is so much
better than it used to be it's true
there are no
negam loans it's hard to qualify you've
got prime borrowers buying instead of a
subprime
is that neither is wrong like i can't
argue
no you can't have an argument kevin
because it's like well
he has not like 30 years experience on
me
you know and he's way more success he's
seen way more so who would like who am i
to argue
my pretty green you know they didn't
mind that's wrong
bull market kevin you don't know what
you're talking about robin hood robin
hood
you know like come on it's stupid like i
do he has
he is married for what he says his
advice for you is most effective for
himself
and i think he would be able to manage
his current assets way better than you
could and you can manage your current
assets way better than he could
that's well yeah that's against a good
one yeah you know one of the things that
uh i have noticed
is that people will uh do you wanna
yeah yeah that just happened uh the
movie recorded exceeded the
ran out of space yeah that's that's you
know just finishing that thought
on on the kevin o'leary i think i think
where he comes from
is maybe seeing people have build wealth
and then lose it all
and then have to start over because he
said i think there was a line he said
oh i you know the last thing you want to
do is have to start over in your 40s
he's not wrong about that there there is
an aspect of you want to put aside
enough of your wealth to where
you've protected the base so to speak so
you never have to start over you know
what i would say though
it would make you know i don't want to
jinx anything
but if something were to happen to
everything and the real estate market
like
drops and the stock market drops and all
income dries up and tenants stop paying
their rent
and you can't sell anything that would
have a traumatic
impact even if you own 50 of everything
outright oh yeah
i mean just going through that then
after if i went through something like
like
i'm knocking on wood here like if
something like that happens
uh i would never want debt ever again so
i think
that's that that's why dave ramsey was
like so anti-debt because he went
through something i think it's
those events could be so traumatic but
that was short-term debt that was like a
three or six month loan
correct yeah yeah yeah well that that
would certainly make you not want to do
that i think those were
30-day interval loans or like a 30-60
day loan hard money yeah hard money
loans it could be called at any time
that he was
trying to renegotiate every 30 60 days
it's
really very risky very risky but things
can happen well and
see look at that's what's so amazing
about america is now you look at
you buy a place with a 30-year
fixed-rate mortgage what happens to the
the property when the
market value falls you drop the rent a
couple hundred bucks
like that's it the bank doesn't call you
and go yo margin call your property call
like you got to sell your bank right now
because you're upside down they don't
care
they just care about getting their
payment and then not even that anymore
because tenant stops paying rent or you
got difficulties
we got forbearance for you we got loan
mods for you we got options for you
this country does not want you to fail
they almost make it
hard to fail in some cases i mean it
would have to be the perfect storm
because i thought about like for me like
what would happen i think it would have
to be a
cataclysmic earthquake yes in california
that would
wipe out all of my rental properties so
then that wouldn't
like from that so that all dries up
let's say but then insurance comes in
because i have earth you have everything
um
but then no one would want to live here
for a long time like the san francisco
fires
it was like 20 years before people
started really rebuilding and moving
back in the area
so there goes your investment i mean
there's everything down 50 percent that
you've that you've accumulated wow and
then i'm thinking if that happens in
conjunction
with let's say something happen it's
happening with youtube or something
happening in the economy if those happen
at the same time
then it's like then what and it just
happens the thing's like it's it's good
it's unlikely but even with the proper
insurances i mean it's just
i've never i can't believe you pay for
earthquake insurance it's so expensive
because the deductible is like
10 to 15 on this house you would have to
sustain
200 000 in damages for your insurance to
begin covering you
and what are you paying 300 bucks a
month for this no no no no it's
not that 200 000 no the land values
this home is probably only worth it it's
i would say about 120 dollars a square
foot
policy man nobody building in la for 120
bucks a foot you can't even remodel for
that
i don't know what the policy says
offhand three to four hundred bucks a
foot is your new construction on a
rebuild
so what is 2200 square feet so a million
bucks
yeah they're putting on i mean sure
they'll take off some land value but
uh i would not be shocked if you have to
cut a six-figure check before you have
your earthquake insurance kick in
before you do that bolt your foundation
for six screws you know
and then what what are your odds of a
nine here like zero
i think uh california like la ventura
your odds of anything over uh seven and
a half or zero
we have like a one percent chance of a
seven and a half and
uh five to fifteen percent of a seven
and
a lot of the newer homes can stand those
now you own some older properties than i
do
uh i actually don't own any properties
older than about 1958.
the 1920s properties which you've got
those i might be more tempted on or just
consider lateraling up to some newer
stuff
yeah my thought is it sort of i mean i
don't want to jinx anything and rather
no no no no no
deal yeah something to think okay
somebody think about it look at your
policy because it's probably 10 to 15
if it's 15 and then look at what it is
because they'll tell you
as to what the value is and what are you
paying 300 a month for this thing
no no no not that much um i know it's
annually like this
i think is like 20 300 a year okay so a
couple hundred bucks a month
uh look it up and take a look at that
usually earthquake insurance is like oh
i'm almost better off paying some
retrofit fees
but uh yeah i don't know i just and i
think that's where i get so excited and
i could talk for hours
just about real estate investing it's
just my perspectives and that doesn't
mean my perspectives are right
uh you know we differ on on things uh
but i did like the remodel that you did
on your thanks
your duplex thank you yeah that's uh
that was really you were supposed to
move in
so we could do and i'm evicting you as a
tenant i'm invicting me kevin
that's true yeah and then the pandemic
started everything happened
what a what crap this needs to end
i'm tired of him i know we should wrap
this up
because we're getting to we're past two
hours oh yeah well
we have a question called graham yeah
you know what to do
yeah uh so the question we ask everybody
oh
would you rather fight one horse-sized
duck or 100 duck sized horses this is a
stephen gardner
or graham this is from stephen gardner's
channel how is it
he asked the same question did he he
asked the same
question he took it from him he got it
from us when did he say it a month ago
yeah we've been doing this for months uh
shut up since like almost the beginning
of the podcast yeah
yep we asked uh our second guest now
yeah we asked christine christine
yeah you asked me on the first podcast
oh i did yeah there we go
steven gardner if you're listening come
on i'm on the podcast
that's a great guy yeah um
well i wasn't listening after i thought
about that so you have to ask again
sorry duck sized horse a duck-sized
horse okay yes yes
wait duck sized waiters no one
horse-sized duck or a hunt
little horses yes for one big duck i'd
rather go with a
fight the big little little little
overwhelms
uh it's like no one says that everyone
would rather the whole bunch of little
ones really
no yeah because i know a horse-sized
duck yeah that's a big duck and the beak
the beak would be powerful yeah it's
going to be slow
it's going to be slow not slow yeah you
can fly too
you can just flap at swings
uh no i i don't know i'd maybe i it's
just like one of those fears where
you're like you go to sleep at night and
you just have these visions of like
spiders coming up and taking over
your body and killing you you know like
i i don't know like
little no no uh
horse size ducks i mean i get it but you
get a bunch of little stuff nibbling at
you that's a problem too
what would would you have any strategy
to it strategy wow i
you know i think if you you got to get
like you just go behind
like a table and like you're on that
side
that's i have no idea uh
you know when i was a police explorer
the strategy was always if somebody
pulls a gun as a police explorer you
have to zigzag run away
i don't think that would work for for a
horse-sized duck
uh to zigzag away maybe you just b-line
it and gtfo
yeah speaking of gtfo-ing i think it's
time to go
cool so with that said you guys thank
you so much for watching really
appreciate it kevin
we'll link to all of your information
down below in the description so
uh you could gain a whole bunch of
subscribers from this man
an extra 10 000 instagram followers on
this right
uh let's see what else subscribe
instagrams down below
everything's down below we with this
episode is long enough guys if you
actually made it to the very end
comment down below and just say you made
it to the very end
jack will be there answering every
comment that has made it to the very end
just say
say okay so here's say it made it to the
very end and then like what little
thing do we have them say just just only
people who made it to this point will
have to know this
shave shave shirt
say made it to the end shave semicolon
semicolon shape done call
so with that said you guys so what
that's to say that so with that city
guys
so with that said you guys thank you so
much for coming to the iced coffee
not uh not not coffee hour and uh
thank you for watching and subscribing
we've got 20
coasters here and it was a blast it's
too hot in here next time we'll do it in
mine
cool all right one thing really quick
move this thumbnail oh yeah
we're just gonna
yeah yeah and i i got destroyed oh man
uh i also did snowboarding for seven
years
uh then i went on skis one time and i
never touched my snowboard again
did you fall no it's just you're always
on your butt in the snow you snowboard
yeah you're always in the snow
yeah but you're always in the snow oh
crap um
can you just flip that yeah that's like
i just
just a little yeah i don't have to sit
my butt in the snow when i'm skiing i
love it
it's so cute it's just anyway okay
but i would snowboard with you all right
taxes so anyway
ready okay there we go i hope you guys
have questions
oh yeah we do oh okay now i'm nervous
all right
you ready okay ready okay here we go
welcome back to the night
oh sorry i saw that i saw that record
all right okay